um thanks for for inviting me to give
this to give this talk it's it's really
an honor to give a lecture in this
series and I also want to first of all
thank you guys everybody for tuning in
from closing far and also the staff at
Simon Star sort of putting together this
remote remote presentation such such a
short time so the talk is titled
lattices intersect quantum and let's see
if I can swap the next slide good and
what I want to talk about is points of
conflict and synergy between lattice
cryptography and quantum computing so as
I guess everybody who's attending knows
assignments is actually running two
programs right now one on lattices in
computer science and one on funding
computing and I think it's a great idea
to have these two programs together
because there's many points of
intersection and what I want to do in
this talk is to give a very very high
level and sometimes oversimplified but I
hope still insightful overview on some
of these some of these points of
intersection and interesting directions
in sort of putting together lattice
cryptography and quantum computing all
right so let's start with quantum
computing you have to start with one of
them so a quantum computer is a device
that uses the physical principles of
quantum mechanics in order to achieve
new computational capabilities and we
have an illustration of a qubit here the
basic unit of information for quantum
computing and why quantum computer is
good so a very interesting application
is just to be able to simulate quantum
physical processes so we have some
quantum physical systems and we want
system and you want to know how it
behaves maybe under different conditions
different temperature different
pressures I don't know so one way to do
it is to just run the experiment but
maybe we don't want to actually make it
a setup to run the experiment every time
we want to be able to simulate it
computer and since it's a quantum
physical system we actually need quantum
computational capabilities for this
purpose and this is useful for
scientific purposes but also for
industrial purposes like perhaps
designing new drugs and materials and so
forth probably some that I don't even
know about
another application of quantum computers
is to generate randomness so using a
quantum device you can actually generate
true randomness that is guaranteed to be
uncorrelated with any other analyst in
the world which is a good idea for
example if you use this randomness as a
key for your for your cryptographic
scheme and this is opposed to what we
sometimes do which is used stochastic
randomness which comes let's say from
the least significant bit of the clock
of your computer or things like that
another application which is of
particular interest for this talk is to
use quantum computer to solve
cryptographic problems such as factoring
or discrete log problems so in
cryptography we base the hardest of
cryptographic schemes the unbreakable D
the security of cryptographic schemes on
the hardness of computational problems
and indeed many of the cryptographic
schemes that we use today are based on
the hardness of factoring large numbers
or computing the discrete log over sum
over some groups and using a quantum
computer these problems can actually be
solved efficiently in polynomial time
which is a problem for the cryptographic
use of these of these schemes so quantum
computers are great and the first thing
that we want to do is to actually build
them so that we can unlock all these all
these great applications and the second
thing that we want to do is to protect
against them and this is not necessarily
in this order since as we said if if
once quantum computers are built they're
going to render some of our
cryptographic schemes insecure we should
already prepare cryptography preparing
you with new cryptographic methods that
will allow us to have security ography
even in the presence of quantum
computers and lattices are one of the
most promising or maybe the most
promising approach towards obtaining
quantum secure post quantum secure
cryptography and in the sense that it
allows us to construct your target field
as far as we know is resilient to
quantum attacks but before we sort of
put all our eggs in this basket we need
to really sort of try to understand as
much as we can what makes these lattice
problems presumably resilient to quantum
attacks
maybe you know in terms of scientific
curiosity even if it doesn't even if we
don't completely break a lattice
cryptography lines cryptographic schemes
we won't understand whether quantum
algorithms can in any situation I'll
perform classical classical ones in the
lattice study so at this point I think I
said the word lad is like maybe 10 times
but I should actually tell you what
lattices are and we're going to do this
right away so a lattice is essentially a
periodic discrete set of points in
Euclidean space usually a high
dimensional Euclidean space on the slide
of course I only have two dimensional
Euclidean space so you have an example
of a lattice and indeed it looks like
this infinite grid of points I cannot
draw an infinite loop point so I drew a
finite section of a lattice and the
property is that if you take two of
these lattice points then you also get a
lattice point you can also think about
it as a discrete additive subgroup on
the Euclidean space RN
and usually the the dimension is grows
asymptotically and if you want actual
numbers to keep in mind and just think
about like say thousand dimensional
lattice so it's big it's much bigger
than two and the way that we represent a
base the way we represent a lattice is
using a basis so if I want to sort of
give you a handle on the lattice give
you a representation of the lattice then
what I can give you is a set of vectors
such that all the lattice points are
obtained as integer combination of these
of these vectors and in this case
dimensional the basis is is too because
dimension of the lattice is also is also
true so the basis actually spans the
lattice when you have integer
coefficients for integer coefficients
for the for the basis vectors a basis is
a representation of the lattice but it's
not a unique representation so a lobby's
can have many different bases so for
example this is also basis for this for
the same lattice I hope at least so a
lot it can have many bases and they can
have very different different properties
what are the computational problems that
we that we care about when we talk about
lattices
so the most basic problems that are
usually considered are the short
shortest vector problem and closest and
closest vector problem so in the
shortest vector problem you're given a
basis for the lattice and you're asked
to find the shortest nonzero the
shortest nonzero vector element in the
lattice so it's kind of easy it's this
guy or this one actually so the reason
why it's easy is because what I gave you
is a two-dimensional lattice as the
dimension increases the hardest of a
problem seems to scale seems the scale
exponentially actually with with the
dimension of the lattice and this is
this is actually becoming a hard problem
and we even care about the approximation
version of this problem so don't just
give me you don't have to even give me
the shortest vector in the lattice but
some short vector that is not much
longer than the shortest one you can
also think about the closest vector
problem which is I'm giving you a target
point like any point in space and you
need to give me back the lattice point
that is closest to this target point or
some point that is not too far from this
from this target point so these are sort
of two canonical problems for lattices
but actually we based when we work with
lattice based cryptography we usually
base on a variant of this problem known
as bounded distance decoding and this
can be seen as sort of an extreme
version of the closest vector problem
where we want to find we get a target
point and we want to find the closest
lattice point but we're guaranteed that
the closest lattice point is actually
very very close so there's a lot this
point that is close that is closer to
our target then any other there's much
much closer to our target than any other
lattice point and and even under this
promise we want to be able to find we
want to be able to find the closest
lattice point so by the way these
problems it's sometimes it's instructive
to think about them as Euclidean
analogue of decoding problem so if you
think about air cracking codes then
again you have these type of problems
where you're getting a word that is
guaranteed to be close to a code word so
it's taking a code word plus a little
bit of noise and you want to be able to
decode and get the code word that that
you thought you came from so let's talk
about the bond distance decoding PDD a
little bit
or me slightly more formal although I'm
not going to be very full on this talk
at all so one way to generate an
instance the BDD is the following
so I'm going to take the zero point and
perturb it a little bit and I'm going to
get what I want to think about is the
noise value so it's this value e which
is very small this value e actually
defines a co set for this lattice so
this there's the set of green points
which is just a coset of the lattice of
robot and the bound in the boundary
since the coding problem I'm given a
random element in this co set or I can
also think of a canonical representation
of this co set and the goal of the
solver is given this given this input to
actually find e which is equivalent to
finding the closest lattice point to
this point Y on the slide and this has a
very simple linear algebraic
representation I can think about the
point Y as taking the basis represented
as a matrix times the vector s which is
an integer vector plus this small
perturbation so I'm giving you this very
simple linear equation with s and E that
are hidden and the goal is to sort of
recover the value recover the value at
the notion of approximation here so the
approximate version of EDD actually sort
of refers to how close the point Y is to
allow this point compared to the second
closest lattice point let's say 2y or
the distance or the minimum distance
between two lattice points so how
extreme we get in sort of enforcing this
promise that the target point is close
to the lattice so there's these large
problems in particular BDD are really a
cryptographic treasure for a few reasons
one is that they lead to like it's
Fantasyland of crypto primitives and I'm
not going to get into details I'm just
going to refer you to the workshop
that's going to take place assignments
next week about cryptographic
applications of lattice problems really
some applications that we maybe a few
years back would have been considered
certain speculation we can actually
found on the hardness of lattice
problems the other useful property is
that lattice problems enjoy worst case
the average case reductions which means
that there exists a distribution of BDD
instances of lattices and points
such that if you sample an instance from
this distribution then your guarantee
you guarantee that it's at least as hard
as solving VDD or solving or even other
lattice problems on worst case lines and
so when any lattice in the world and
this is very useful for cryptography
because we don't need to think very hard
on which distribution to use for our
crypto systems so for cryptography we
need to sample an instance and this
gives us away the sample instance that
is in a sense the hardest one so this is
also a useful property and the last
property is well the resilience to
quantum attacks which is what we are
going to talk about now so let's try to
see how quantum attacks actually solve
cryptographic salt cryptograph legacy
cryptographic problems and then try to
understand whether we can do something
also for the case of lattices so the way
quantum algorithm again this is going to
be very high level the way quantum
algorithms solve problems like factoring
or discrete log is by casting them as
problems known as period finding finding
or hidden subgroup problem and I'm going
to talk about period finding and this is
the following this is the following
problem so the task that we have is to
find a hidden number P you can think
about this Prime but it doesn't have to
be given access to an Oracle that
depends on P and of course it really
depends on what this Oracle is we're
going to talk about in a second but the
running time should be polynomial in the
size of the representation of P so the
running time should be poly log in this
in this number P that we have so what is
this Oracle o P so let's start with an
easy Oracle so let's think about an
Oracle that given any integer X just
returns X mod p and of course finding P
given such an Oracle is very easy even
even classically so now this Oracle
actually always gives you the same
answer on every core set of the integers
modulo P so the answer the Oracle only
depends on the co set modulo P that your
the your input is but this Oracle also
gives you a very convenient name for the
co sets and the question is what happens
in the course that have random names so
let's just use colors so instead of
telling you what x mod p is you're just
going to input an X and you're gonna get
a response I'd know pink
if you have two different XS that have
the same value modulo P then you're
going to get the same color but
otherwise you're going you're going to
get different colors and the question is
given an Oracle of this form can you can
you find P and now this is a harder task
and indeed classically you can actually
cannot do it in in polynomial time in
polygon P time but turns out that this
is where quantum algorithms actually
have an advantage and the way that
quantum algorithms actually solve this
problem in polynomial time is using a
technique known as quantum Fourier
transform I'm not going to define
Fourier transform I assume that the vast
majority of the audience know what it is
but anyway although we need to know for
the purpose of this talk is that the
Fourier transform is an operator on
functions that have the following
properties property actually just one so
what I want is that when I feed you when
I feed the Fourier transform with a
periodic function so in this case a
function by the way you can see my arrow
right can you see my arrow that's
wiggling here yes excellent so when I'm
giving you as input a periodic function
so in this case this is a function with
period P then when you apply Fourier
transform on this function then the
output is actually going to be a
discrete a discrete function and this
function is only going to be supported
over multiples of 1 over P so
periodicity in the input actually leads
to discreteness to discreteness on the
output and why is this useful because
given access to this color Oracle that I
described practice hiking here given
access to this color Oracle that I just
described we can actually generate a
quantum state which is in superposition
over sort of over s given coset mod p so
given the sort of the monochromatic
given a monochromatic set set of points
so I'm I didn't say what quantum state
is and I didn't say what a superposition
is but for our purposes it suffices to
say that a superposition or a quantum
state can represent the function
can represent a function of this form
and using the color Oracle I can I can
generate a superposition which is
periodic over the over the core sets of
this of the integers mod so once I
generate this once I generate the
superposition I can apply this quantum
Fourier transform which can be done
efficiently this allows us to perform
the Fourier transform operation on the
function that is defined by the quantum
state and this is going to give us a new
quantum state that is only supported
over multiples of 1 over P then what we
do is measure this quantum state which
is again something that I didn't define
but for our purposes when you measure a
quantum state you get some value in the
support of this thing where the
probability that is proportional to the
square of the amplitude but again this
these details are not going to matter
for us what's important is you're going
to get a multiple of 1 over P and if you
do this like a couple of times and you
get a few multiples of 1 over P then you
should be able to recover 1 over P and
then recover P itself and this is how
these algorithms algorithms work and of
course I'm omitting a lot of details so
for example a periodic function is
necessarily infinite whereas the quantum
states that we can efficiently represent
are necessarily finite finite so we have
to take that into account but all of
these things can be resolved I think the
high level picture that I want that I
want you to have is that we start from a
periodic function over the co set and go
to a discrete function over multiples of
multiples of 1 over P and this this is
the tool and you can actually use that
solve factoring and n discrete log and
actually this also works in higher
dimensions and sometimes you actually
meet it for some of these problems and
interestingly you can even think about
it in lattice terminology so we can
think about the lattice this is a one
dimensional lattice of all multiples of
P and if we think about this lattice
then this function we can actually think
of as a periodic function over the core
sets of the lattice so it's a function
that is defined over the entire space
but for Fe for all the points that
belong to the same concept of the
lattice this function takes the same
value and what happens with quantum
Fourier transform when you apply or with
Fourier transform when you
apply Fourier transform on such a
function on such a lattice periodic
function what you actually get is is
another function which is discrete and
is only supported over a different
lattice now the lattice is the multiples
of 1 over P and this different lattice
is known as the dual lattice of our of
our original lattice and a nice way to
think about it even though again this is
not fully rigorous but it can be made
rigorous is that the dual out this is
essentially the Fourier transform
transform of the original lattice and in
the sense that if your periodic over the
original lattice when you apply create
transform you're going to get something
in the discrete over the dual lattice so
this is how we solve factoring and
discrete log and now let's see if we can
sort of take these techniques and pour
them to the lattice world so you know
that the least that we can do we need to
check is that we can just sort of apply
it and just get the polynomial time
glados out good that would be
unfortunate for lattice cryptography but
a good thing for quantum algorithms so
again as we said as I said this sort of
previous period finding or quantum
Fourier transform technique actually
allows you to recover a basis for the
dual lattice all these multiples of 1
over P that we recovered if you think
about in the in the high dimensional
regime it is actually going to give you
a bunch of points in the do a lattice
which you can sort of put together to
actually get a basis for the dual
lattice so this is this is something
that you can do but this is these are
not the problems that we talked about
before when we talked about hard lattice
problems so this is not going to allow
you to find short vectors in the lattice
or or to do decoding and the reason is
that if we're if you're only thinking
about sort of using some sort of color
oracle or only using the fact that the
function is fixed on all the points in a
corset
we actually don't take into account the
geometric properties they actually
define the problems that we want to
solve so we want to be able to decode
for courses that are very close to the
lattice point but like the color Oracle
that I described before doesn't even
distinguish between courses are close to
the lattice and courses that are far
from the lads so this this sort of
technique at least as is seems to lack
sir very strong component
that will allow it to be applicable for
the lattice problems that we care about
but let's not give up just yet because
it seems like this technique is powerful
and does give us something also in the
context in the context of lattices so
let's not give up just yet and try to
see what we need to do in order to be
able to adapt this technique also to the
also the logical novice region so the
things to keep in mind is as I said we
need to use the geometry we need to take
it the closeness into account the other
precaution that we need to take is sort
of not to do too well and the reason is
that the exact version of these lattice
problems that I that I mentioned are
np-hard and we also have a worse case to
average based reduction here so if you
if you come up with a quantum algorithm
then it has to somehow discriminate
between instances which between the
parameter regimes of the problem that
are np-hard which we don't usually hope
to solve in in bqp in quantum polynomial
time and these instances on which we
wish to get an advantage so if you want
to get invent an algorithm that needs to
take this point into into account and
what I want to talk about next is a few
cases where we actually can get some
advantage using in the in the lattice
regime using quantum techniques so this
is not going to be a quantum polynomial
time algorithm for general adders
problem this is not something that we
know how to get but it is going to be
cases where we have quantum techniques
that allow us to perform some
computational tasks that we don't know
how to perform classically in the
context of lattices so I'm going to
mention three examples one is in the
context of quantum reductions so we
don't know how to how to actually get
quantum polynomial time algorithm for
lattice problems but we can but it is
possible to show that if you have an
appropriate Oracle then you can you can
actually take advantage of this Oracle
in quantum ways that you cannot that you
cannot do classically and I'm going to
say more about this in the next slide
and this actually leads to quantum
reduction so it's a reduct it's
reductions between problems that we can
perform quantumly and we don't know how
to how to do classically the second
example that I'm not sure that I'm going
to I'm going to get to talk about in
detail is again you can think about as a
type of reduction and this is a way to
use non-trivial algo non trivial quantum
algorithms for problem known as the
dihedral corset problem so this is a
problem that is defined on on a quantum
input and for which we have an on for
each to exist a non-trivial quantum
algorithm and it's possible to show that
this problem is actually connected our
two lattice problems and in fact if we
can get slightly less trivial even less
trivial algorithms than the one that we
currently the one that are currently
known then this will actually lead to a
quantum advantage for four lattice
problems even in the even in the general
settings setting
I should mention that whenever I'm
talking about sort of quantum speed-up
or a quantum advantage so forth in the
context of this talk I'm talking about
super polynomial about superpolynomial
speed-up
however in many settings you might might
care about polynomial speed-up as well
so I thought I'd mention it's a familial
speed-up could also be important for
quantum cryptography but in this talk
what we care about is super polynomial
speed the third example is actually the
first thing that I'm going to very
briefly mention and this is actually
case where we do have super polynomial
quantum advantage for lattice problems
but not for general lattice problem is
brute force for specific class of
lattices that are known as ID lattices
so let me very briefly not tell you what
ID lattices are and yet try to sort of
give you an idea on what happens here
because I think it's really nice and
you'll see in a minute why I'm calling
it cheating of course that the algorithm
works it's not cheating but it's
cheating in the sense that it doesn't
follow these guidelines or warning signs
that I just mentioned so it's very nice
that you're able to get around them in
certain certain cases so in this case
there's a quantum polynomial time
algorithm that solves BDD and also other
lattice problems
on this class of ideal addresses and it
does so and it gives an approximation
factor that if you wanted to get
classically you'd have to run in some
exponential time so it's it's a
significant it's a significant advantage
and the one thing that I'm going to tell
you about ideal addresses is that this
is a type of lattices that can be
represented by a generator which is an
algebraic object and this this generator
actually defines the basis for the
lattice but this module is also has
betas bases that are not necessarily a
generator this the the quantum quantum
advantage here is achieved by an
algorithm that takes two steps the first
step is to find some lattice generator
not all bases for the lattice are
generators so we need to work in order
to be able to find some generator for
the lattice and here I don't care about
the geometry of the lights all I care
about is this sort of algebraic task of
finding finding a generator and the
second step is going from this generator
which could represent a long basis for
the lattice so bad bases for the lattice
to a generator that represents a short
basis for the lattice which allows us to
solve the bdd problem and the nice thing
here is that you use the quantum
techniques only for the first step so
the first step which actually doesn't
care about the geometry is the one where
we use the the one where we get the
quantum speed-up and then for the second
step you use you can use you do use the
geometry you have to use it somewhere
but you only use it in the second step
to go from the long to the shore
generator so this is sort of a way to
sort of get around what I said before
that you know your quantum algorithm
needs to take the geometry in this case
you take the geometry into account in
the classical part of the algorithm so
this is really cool and this is a really
interesting and exciting Avenue for for
research whether you can extend it into
other regimes and other classes of
lattices I should mention that as it
stands it's not applicable for standard
cryptographic regimes both because of
the approximation the approximation
factor that is being achieved which is
usually bigger than what you people use
in crypto and because ID lattices are
usually not used for cryptography per se
use related lattices that are known as
modular dices and for that kind of
lattices we don't know how to get this
kind
so now let me spend some time talking
about this
si BP to vdd reduction by this is a
reduction by Reagan I did not say and I
will not say what this si VP thing is
but let me sort of say well we actually
going to show so what we show is that if
you if I give you access to a BDD Oracle
so an Oracle that solved this BDD
problem that I described then it's
possible to find short vectors in the
dual lattice so remember this duel ad is
that we talked about I didn't show you
what the dual of this lattice looks like
but we're going to be able to get
vectors in the dual lattice that are
fairly short and why is this good well
for once if you have short vectors in
the dual lattice then you can actually
solve the BDD problem so this gives you
a way to start from a BDD Oracle and
just by sort of having Oracle access to
this to the solver of this problem you
can actually sort of recover what's
known as the trapdoor or is a way to
actually solve BDD for any instance in
the future without actually looking at
this Oracle so this is a sort of very
nice a very nice property to have and
let me sort of more specifically say
that when I'm talking about it beating
the Oracle this is an organ that takes
as input a lattice a lot of spaces B and
in factor Y and recovers this
perturbation eda we were talking that we
were talking about before and and I
should say that this is this reduction
is also sort of lattice preserving so
I'm giving you a BDD Oracle for a given
lattice and you're going to get short
vectors in the dual of this specific
lattice so this is also sort of a nice a
nice feature you don't need to solve BDD
on questions because that's the original
idea so if you have if you have short
vectors in the dual this allows you to
solve BDD in the primal lattice in the
original ass
Hika do you need the PT the Oracle to
work with probability one or it works
with any small probability so it's a
suffice that works in small probability
but for the purpose of the slide I mean
I'm going to assume that works with
probability one okay okay so um good so
the first thing that we notice when we
try to do something with a BDD Oracle is
that it seems it seems kind of useless
when when you when you try to try to
play with it because in order to use a
BDD Oracle I need to feed it with a lot
I need to give it a basis for the
lattice B and also the point Y which
needs to be close to the lattice so how
do we generate this how do i generate
this point y so if the point Y is not
close to the lattice then the worker can
do whatever it wants and maybe I'm not
going to be able to get any useful
information on the obvious way to do it
is to take a lattice point and perturb
it a little bit and indeed this way you
will get a point Y that is a value input
to the Oracle but in that case the
response of the Oracle is completely
useless because it's only going to give
you back the perturbation that you
started from so at least at first glance
it seems like it's going to be pretty
hard to take advantage of take advantage
of a bdd Oracle but let's not not not
let's not lose hope let's sort of go
back our quantum for the Fourier
transform tools and see how this Fourier
transform which again relates periodic
functions on the primal to discrete
functions of the dual can help us in
sampling short vectors in the dual and
indeed the point is that the shape of
the the shape of the periodic function
is going to matter so before when I
talked about the color or a kill I
thought about I was talking about
uniform superposition over cosine now
what we're going to do is generate a
superposition with an appropriate shape
such that when you take the quantum
Fourier transform you take the Fourier
transform of the shape you are actually
going to be supported only over or
mostly over short vectors in the dual
lattice and yeah so this is going to be
this going to be our goal to generate a
quantum state whose quantum Fourier
transform is mostly supported over short
points in the dual and not over uniform
points the dual
I'm not going to tell you why this is
the case those of you who worked a
little bit with Fourier transform
probably sir please have something to
ition but if I could replace each
lattice point with just a just a ball
and I define a function again this
lattice periodic function that is
defined by the sequence of this balls
then the quanta Fourier transform of
this function is indeed going to be
supported mostly over over short over
short vectors in the in the dual so this
is going to be our task now to generate
this superposition and if you can do
this then then we're going to be able to
sort of solve our problem and get and
get short dual vectors and these balls
should have a radius as big as we can
get we will see that we're going to have
a limitation on the radius of the balls
that we can generate good so let's see
how to how do we generate this type of
superpositions how do we generate this
type of superposition so the approach is
actually pretty similar to what we try
to do before when we sort of attempted
to utila to classically utilize the BDD
Oracle so we can generate a
superposition over all the lattice
points and then from for each of these
lattice points actually create a little
ball around this is something that you
can actually do efficiently but it
suffers even though it's quantum and
it's a superposition it suffers from the
exact same problem that we that I
mentioned that I mentioned before each
point in the ball that you generate is
actually sort of remember so it's
associated with the lattice point that
that it came from and this and this type
of superposition is actually very
different from a soup position of balls
that sort of don't remember the lattice
point that they originated from so the
task now is the start from the
superposition of sort of centered bowls
and remove the center of the ball and
this is what we are going to use the BDD
Oracle for so notice that if we sort of
feel any point in the support of this
any point in the support of the
superposition into the BDD Oracle it's
going to give me the center of the ball
that I started from
this is guaranteed that the balls are
small enough that the BDD Oracle is
actually supposed to be is guaranteed to
solve on this on this radius so the BDD
Oracle actually allows us to compute
given any point in the superposition the
center of the ball that it came from and
in the quantum regime if you can compute
something then you can also erase it so
being able to compute the center of the
ball actually allows you to remove the
centers from all these balls and arrived
from this centered superposition into
this sort of just superposition of balls
without origin that is required in order
to in order to get this sampler for for
short transport so this is yeah I see
that there is a question sorry I I'm not
sure if I understand white means to
remove the center in the most your
picture it looks like you know I can
always see the center anyway it's not
clear you can always see the center
anyway right because if you look at this
if you let's if you look at the
superposition so if you're if you're
just thinking about so the superposition
you can think about it is like just a
formal sum of all the possible points in
this in this in this regime so you're
actually going to going to have a formal
sum of all the points in all the balls
so if you're looking at a given point in
the sum then you're not necessarily
going to know what is the center of the
ball that this point belongs to because
this is exactly the BDD problem you
cannot do this efficiently so it
actually does have a meaning whether you
whether I'm telling you whether it's a
formal sum over like a point in the
center later that originated from or
whether it's a formal son only over
points without without center
essentially makes a difference let me
just understand it correctly that the
center is still information
theoretically bit to mean so when you
remove is sort of in some sorbet a
compute computational or right so yeah
its information theoretically I can
always generate these things information
theoretically there's no problem the
question is how to do it efficiently and
in order to do it efficiently I need
something like BDD I need to be able to
sort of get from from a point in the
ball on to its respective center
um so yeah oh it's another question it's
still about the same so the distribution
that you generated is always correct can
I think obvious that before you remove
the center there is some sort of
register that has the center written in
it
after you remove it and under the
register disappear right yeah I didn't
want to get into sort of formal
description of quantum registers and so
on but since you asked let me say it if
you don't want if you don't want to know
about quantum registers you can wait
until I'm done with the sentence so yeah
so what you get get is you have to part
two registers one that contains the
center and this is going to be a
superposition over all at this point and
the other one is going to contain this
is going to contain these element the
elements of the poles so the element in
the ball is always going to be
associated with its center and what we
do use the BDD Oracle it sort of arrays
the information in the register to
contain the center so that we can sort
of remove this without without
collapsing our superposition and
actually get the balls thanks yeah so
this is what I want to say for now about
sort of quantum algorithms for lattice
problems and let me talk a little bit
about the synergy part so about how to
use cryptography in order to in order to
get you know to improve the way that we
can use the way that we uses quantum
computers we talked about quantum
computers and we said we said was there
a question yes this is Ben nose so this
type of production we we don't know how
to do it without quantum right but we do
that's right we don't have any negative
indications right there's no negative
right that they you know yeah you're
pre-empting you're pre-empting my open
question slide yeah but there's
certainly a good question whether this
type of what this type of reduction or
you know any other reduction between BDD
and si VP can be can be done without
quantum powers mom right now we don't
know how to do it and not for lack of
trying I think but there have been many
where we had quantum advantage and it
turned out after a while that there's
actually classical methods to achieve
similar to achieve similar performance
so there are other tricks that you can
do with the BDD Oracle that give you
non-trivial that give you non-trivial
exact non-trivial advantage for other
problems but not for this problem of
finding short vectors in the dual
lattice so I thought I think there was
another question I can hardly speak a
bit louder so it's better now yes okay
so as we are talking about reduction so
so you refer to this BDD as an Oracle
but it's not entirely clear if an Oracle
is really enough I mean if I give you an
Oracle that is implemented you know you
don't know how but perhaps it is you
know exponential time or anything I do
you can make queries I'll give you the
answer maybe you can even make quantum
queries I will give you the quantum
answers but is this enough to carry out
to the process that you are describing
or you do need indeed a seer quit and
you need to say that or this operation
can be performed by a polynomial size C
requite right so if I understand
correctly you're you're just you're
talking about what your question applies
even to what is the notion of a quantum
reduction right so normally when we talk
about reductions what is the what is the
purpose of showing a reduction between
problems sorry for starting with sort of
varies or trivial trivial statement so
when we when we show reduction why what
we want to say is that if we have an
efficient and efficient algorithm that
solves problem a then we're going to
have an efficient algorithm that solves
that solves problem B and it is indeed a
question of how to how to state this
also in the quantum setting so certainly
you need to define what it means they
actually get quantum access to to an
Oracle and this notion of reduction
needs to sort of respect the we respect
our goal which is to say that if we have
an efficient quantum or classical
a efficient quantum classic algorithm
problem then we also get from the
reduction in efficient algorithm to
problem B this is this your impassible
selenium or a directly as would you say
that this reduction is black box or non
black box so it's I would say to the
reduction it's black box but it is true
and it is interesting to think what is
the correct notion of a black box
reduction in the context of quantum
algorithms so for example if you given
given oracle access to a quantum
algorithm it's actually weaker then
being then being given the circuit even
in ways that we consider to be black box
so for example for if a quantum
algorithm is represented as a circuit
then if I'm giving you the actual
circuit then you should you actually
have a way to recover a circuit that
computes the inverse of this function so
so is it so if I'm giving you if I'm
giving you oracle access to a function
in the quantum setting if i'm give you
some black box access to a to a function
in the quantum setting then shouldn't i
also give you an oracle not just to the
to the function itself but also to some
inverse of this function or to a way to
do conditional execution of this
function so the question of what the
difference between oracle access and
black box access in the quantum setting
does make sense but here you're actually
using the weakest the weakest notion
which is all I'm asking is to have
quantum access to this to this worker
okay thanks
ok so yeah so we said we said that
Quanah computers are great and we should
try to build them so going back to point
number one let's try to build a quantum
computer so this is a hard task you
don't just need one qubit you need many
qubits and you need to connect them in
the right way and you need to keep them
coherent so keep them from blue
information to the environment and these
are sort of engineering ly hard tasks
and scalable so fully scalable quantum
computers that can run any quantum
algorithm that we want seem rather
distant as things stand and it should be
careful in this audience so if someone
in the audience has something to report
in this in this respect then I'm all be
happy to hear some news about this but
as far as I know it seems like it's
we're still pretty far from fully
scalable quantum computers and so this
means that we should not expect in our
living room anytime soon and when they
are built it's more likely that they're
at least the first step they're going to
be owned by a big companies and we're
not going to have direct access to them
but rather only access from remote and
this brings up the question of how to
utilize a remote quantum computer that
is possibly owned by an entity that you
don't necessarily trust trust so the
setting that we're going to have as in
the first step
probably a quantum computing is that
there going to be some entity that
claims that they have a quantum computer
and we with our classical calculator
capabilities are only going to have
classical communication access to this
this supposed alleged quantum device and
we're going to and we still want to get
utility out of this out of the situation
so this brings about a bunch of
questions and it turns out that lattice
cryptography can actually be helpful in
sort of approaching a number of these a
number of these aspects that that come
up in this study so the first thing that
I'm going to mention is this notion of
proof of computational quantum it so
someone claims that they constructed a
quantum computer and the first thing
that you want to check is that indeed
this device can perform a computational
task that we don't know how to perform
using a classical computer so this is
actually indeed done using techniques
that are not there are not a lot of
photography but as I will I'll try to
explain
slide if you use that it's crypto then
we can get proofs of wantonness with sir
favorable some favorable properties -
what is that what is currently known so
next thing maybe you don't just want to
show that your device can do something
you actually want to use it for like a
useful purpose and one thing that you
can hope for is to use the quantum
device to generate randomness for you
but you want to generate it with in such
a way that you're certified that the
quantum device indeed sort of used
quantum measurements in order to
generate your randomness and it's not
just sort of give you classical
randomness and claiming that it's that
it's quantum leap generated so this is
this notion of certifiable quantum
randomness another test that you can
think of is a verifiable delegation so
you you have a quantum algorithm and
you're giving you're given to the
algorithm to the untrusted quantum
device and hope that it runs it and you
want to verify that indeed this quantum
device executed the algorithm that you
wanted so you want to get some proof or
ability to verify classically the
outcome of a quantum computation so
another thing that you want to do with
the remote server so I'm going with sort
of increasing levels of sort of optimism
and once you know everything is solved
and we know that the quantum sir the
quantum device actually does what we
want it to do well we can also try to
think about privacy
and when we send information to this
quantum server to compute on maybe you
want to maintain the privacy of our of
our input and this leads to this notion
of private delegation or quantum fully
homomorphic encryption which is somewhat
related but also quite different from
this notion of blind computing for those
of you so this is we want a way to sort
of completely classically encrypt
information that and still allow a
quantum device to process and it turns
out that you can use can use lattice
based cryptography in insert the obvious
things that we use cryptography right
cryptography gives a weak weak entity
the ability to sort of it gives you we
can
it gives the weak entity so leverage
even over some stronger adversary and if
you have quantum resilient cryptography
then you get leverage even even over
quantum adversaries so tomorrow because
this sort of calls it the classical
leash having a quantum so I
cryptographic leash on quantum on
quantum computers and and I think it's
sort of a nice picture to keep in mind
so the cryptography actually allows you
to sort of put a leash even if you're a
classical entity on a quantum device so
the last thing that I want to talk about
a little bit more is about this notion
of proof of computational quantumness
and sort of the different approaches and
what is the difference of the approach
that uses lattice so as I said in this
context what we want is the demonstrated
computational tasks that can be
performed by existing quantum computer
but not by comparable to machine by
comparable by comparable classical
device and I should say that at least my
opinion this notion of proof of
computational quantumness is somewhat of
a philosophical question more than a
mathematical question we're not going to
have like a proof or even even a
practical question we're not necessarily
going to have a proof that we achieved
computational quantumness are we going
to all we all we have is evidence sort
of saying that a certain computational
task we do not expect to be performed by
a comparable by a comparable classical
computer so what it means for classical
computer to be comparable to the quantum
device that we're talking about is also
something that is not is not a it's not
formally defined this is subject to
interpretation
and of course what we what we really
want is to sort of demonstrate this
asymptotically but this you can never do
the only thing that we can hope is the
sort of demonstrated on sufficiently
large inputs so we're convinced that
this actually something asymptotic is
happening but still we really want to
achieve this task want for once because
there's a lot of money and a lot of
energy going into building these quantum
computer so we want to know that at
least we're doing something that there's
not a
there was not a tumor before using
classical devices and the second thing
sort of made more scientifically or
philosophically is that this is going to
give evidence to for refuting the
extension extended searching
hypothesis that says essentially the
opposite that any sort of process
occurring in nature you can simulate
using a classical device with comparable
resources to this sort of physical
process that you you started from and if
we show an in particular quantum
computation is a physical process and if
it cannot be performed by a classical
device then this is evidence for
refuting this extended turn showing up
so how can we do this how can we do
proof of quantumness so one thing is to
just use Shor's algorithm as I said we
have quantum polynomial time algorithm
for this problems that we don't believe
to have classical or that some people
believe that there is no classical
currently not known at least so under
the complexity assumption that the
factory or discrete log problem is not
in its non-ppp it's not computable real
time if we can implement chores
algorithm then we can get proof of
computation of this the problem here of
course is as I said that actually
executes run this algorithm requires a
scalable quantum computer which is
currently out of reach logically the
other approach which actually works is
sort more tailored to the quantum
devices that we currently that are
currently already constructed and the
idea here is to use the existing quantum
device in order to sample from a
distribution which is hard to sample
from using classical device so again
this is under a complexity assumption
that there exists the distribution
particular this particular distribution
that these quantum devices sample from
and this distribution cannot be sampled
from using just classical randomized
algorithms so again you need to sort of
assume some separation between what can
be done in quantum polynomial time and
what can be done in short classical
randomized polynomial time and this
approach is indeed works and is
implemented
and google has this has run this
experiment they call this notion quantum
supremacy and they they were able to
sample from this distribution which is
assumed to be hard for for classical
samplers but now that we have this they
have this collection of samples the
question is how do you verify that the
quantum device actually samples from the
correct distribution even if you do
accept the assumption that this
distribution is hard for classical for
classical devices in the way that this
is currently done is by sort of
employing very strong classical
supercomputers that run in exponential
time and verify that verify the result
of this the result of this computation
and this brings up a lot of challenges a
lot of questions but in particular the
problem is that this approach seems to
only take us to like the current level
of technology once quantum computers
become large enough and we want a sample
from distributions there are complex
enough so we want to show we want to
know that we actually have quantum
capabilities of hundred qubits and out
of 50 cubits then running in classical
exponential time to verify is actually
going to become completely unfeasible so
this approach is works very well and
achieve this great great result with
respect to current technology but there
are questions of how you can scale it
when as quantum computers become more
and more elaborate the third approach
that I that I mentioned before
relying on lattice cryptography is
actually by doing a multi round protocol
so both the approach approaches that I
mentioned so far are just doing
challenge response you send something to
the to the quantum device and it sends
you something back here we actually have
something that runs in actually our
basic algorithm the basic protocol runs
in just four rounds but still it's not
just challenge response and the
assumption that we use is the hardest of
latest problems and this is a little
interesting because lattice problems as
I sort of just said so far are assumed
or as far as we know or hard even for
quantum devices so assuming that the lwe
or that assuming that lattice problems
are hard
actually does not separate any notion
does not separate the complexity class
bqp from VPP and yet even though we
relying on an assumption that does not
separate these complexity classes you
are still able to show a computational
quantum computation task that is
presumed to be hard classically so this
is one sort of interesting feature of
this of this approach at least
theoretically in terms of in terms of
practice or terms of efficiency at least
our verifier does not need to run an
exponential time needs run polynomial
time however the verification process is
not public so since we're using
cryptography this classical very going
to sort of generate some secret key that
is going to help at the second it's
going to generate a secret key it's
going to use it's going to use in order
to sort of try to catch the quantum
device so we get efficient verification
but this efficient verification requires
a secret key what was the question it's
because I think I miss what you said
about assuming out of you is hardly
better than imply something it seems
like that's analog between 1 & 3 which
is that if we believe out of you is hot
then the same way we believe that
Factory is hot then so in so notice that
here we need to assume some separation
between bqp and BPD we need to assume
there's a computational problem that is
solvable in quantum polynomial time but
not in classical polynomial time here we
don't make any any assumption it's
possible that b QP is equal to B P P so
any computational any language it is
decidable or even any distribution that
is sample using a quantum device can
also be efficient example ball by a
classical or or computed by a classical
computer and yet you can sort of devise
an interactive computational task that
sort of separates these these two things
so you can have quantum advantage even
if BB P is equal to B Q P which is kind
of nice to think about so this leads me
to the end of to the end of the talk
sort of looking ahead some of these
things you already asked so it's it's
sort of continue and try to explore
further and understand where and what
type of quantum advantage we can get
four lattice problems in particular in
the cryptographic regime and this is
important also for the real world
because people actually intend to use
lattice cryptography well and people are
do intend to construct quantum computers
so these things are going to sort of
meet hopefully at some point in the
future and so the example that I gave
with idea lattices is something that I
think is not fully understood to what is
the extent that you can bring it is
there actually a gap between ID lattices
and general alysus in this context and
and how much more you can how much more
you can leverage this type of techniques
des quantizing the quantum izing the
reduction that we talked about is a
question that already already came up
another point that I did not mention so
far is to try to sort of apply these
quantum techniques also to other
allegedly quantum resilient
cryptographic problems such as problems
that rely on error correcting code so
decoding Proms are--like relate to the
coding of random error correcting codes
such as the learning parity with know
his problem so if I set it in the
quantum techniques we only know very
little in the coding regime we know I
want to say nothing but I don't I know
nothing I don't know of any way to sort
of get analogues of the things that we
know in the lattice regime to work to
work in this miss coding regime and
that's sort of very interesting question
what it actually means for the heart
quantum hardness of these problems in
terms of using a large cryptography in
that quantum setting as I said you we
want to be able to generate so this
notion of scalable proofs of quantumness
so won't to actually be able to this is
even a notion a question of definition
to define what it means that you did
just it didn't just prove to me that you
have quantum powers but you prove to me
that you have hundred qubits worth of
quantum power and actually devised
algorithms that don't only guarantee
that you you did something that could
not have been done classically but also
something that could not have been done
using
smaller quantum computer so this is
something that I think should should be
should be addressed you think about
improvements for the certifiable
randomness and verifiability protocols I
did not talk about and better
understanding of the power of this
cryptographic leash this is still a new
technique and we essentially have just
one example of how to use it given that
it's photography and and it's important
important to understand whether we can
use in other places or find other
instances associations for this type of
thing thank you very much yeah I think
we're probably out of time but I'm happy
to answer questions I have a question
yeah speaker this is Shweta can you go
back to your second last slide this one
this one yeah so I'm just trying to
understand this proof of computational
quantumness as I understood you said
that if I'm a weak device and I'm going
to have to talk to a quantum computer
that's owned by industry or something
right I want to make sure that did they
actually have the quantum power that
they're claiming to have so this is a
proof that gives us that right so we get
convinced it that whatever it is that
they were doing cannot have been done by
a classical device
exactly yeah so I got that what I'm
trying to understand is that in terms of
the usual applications that we have
where there's a weak client and a
powerful server right so this proof of
computational quantum this has to be
built in into every application that we
have what I mean to say is that let's
say that you know we run this proof of
computational quantumness and now I'm
convinced that Google or whoever it is
that I'm talking to is indeed a powerful
quantum computer how could I be sure
that the next that next time when I ask
them to do some work for me they're
actually using this quantumness
so yes yeah so yeah that's the question
so basically I want to not just know
that they have this power but I want to
be sure that they're using it for me so
in some sense just knowing that they
have the power is not really going to
help me right right so this is a
completely accurate what you just said
so just knowing that they have the power
is not going to help you this is just
the first step however if you're if you
invested a lot of money time effort and
energy in constructing in constructing a
device and you're saying well you know
it's going to take I don't know 5 more
years 10 more years for this device to
do something useful then at least as a
sanity check you'd want to know that
whatever that you're on the right track
right so this is a way this is by itself
this proof of computational quantumness
is by itself not necessary not
necessarily useful for any particular
task but rather just a way to show that
we managed to construct a device that
has powers that are different from the
devices that were known to be
constructed so far it has a very limited
capacity and this is why I only
mentioned it sort of is a first step in
this sort of hierarchy of tasks that we
want to perform once once that's sort of
more and more elaborate quantum computer
so it's something it's something then
that's more useful from the service
point of view like if if I'm the server
then I want to prove to you that I do
have this power that classical computer
is doing right it's not something we
should think of as benefiting the client
per se right the modeling is in the
model of this clients everybody of this
proved of a fire but actually you know
in this setting both of them are
actually going to be the same entity and
it's just us that are sort of skeptical
as to whether something that was
constructed is actually is actually a
quantum computer or not this is actually
good also is a sanity check maybe you
know I think that I constructed the
quantum computer but I want to verify
even for my own sake that this this
thing that the thing that is constructed
actually does the task that it actually
performs a task that is inherently
quantum but it is important for the
verifier to be classical
right yes exactly for because me well
you could think of a weak quantum device
verifying a strong quantum device and
this is something that has been studied
in the literature extensively but yeah
the ultimate goal is to be able to do it
completely classically so that even you
know classical beings like you know
ourselves can be convinced without sort
of any need for a mediator we can be
convinced that something quantum has
happened okay cool Thanks anybody else
okay my guess is that the next talk we
have will probably be all remote I think
it's kind of an educated guess so I
think that's next week in the workshop
all right starting on Monday morning I
mean that's a workshop talk it was
supposed to be in this in this room so
thank you very much speaker I know
thanks everyone for tuning in and thanks
for having me remotely laughing to you